cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now
david first of all this note which we
thought was a pretty remarkable number
and a marker
uh the number of americans fully
vaccinated 28.7 million
is now almost exactly the number of
americans infected
since the beginning of the pandemic
which is 28.8 million
for those who get the vaccinations the
cdc as we mentioned has delayed that
guidance what do you expect it will be
when it comes out
i think the guidance is going to say the
following is that you can get together
in small groups
of vaccinated individuals where everyone
is vaccinated without a mask
but whenever you go out in public
whenever you go
out of the house you have to wear a mask
and you have to social distance
if somebody is vaccinated they can have
a low level of virus but another
vaccinated person
should have enough immunity to deal with
that so it's going to be different rules
for those who are vaccinated
in the house but the same when we go out
so a growing number of states you have
texas you have mississippi
connecticut opening up
easing restrictions really what do you
say to
those states is that something you
encourage or certainly frown upon
well the problem is something that
happens in texas affects the rest of the
country because people travel
the only reason to let down a mass
mandate to take it away is political
when you look at the data the data are
clear we have to continue wearing masks
for several more months we have to
social distance if we
don't do those things we're going to
have a continued spread of the virus and
with these new variants
i am worried that it's going to be a
very quick rise in number of cases
david one of the debates that i feel
like we've seen since the johnson
johnson vaccine was approved for use is
this idea that it's not
as effective as the other vaccines
people not wanting to take them we've
also heard from some religious leaders
there's just been a lot of talk saying
that's not the one for me can you remind
people again
why all of these vaccines are worth
taking and it's not worth
picking and choosing get what you can
get
thank you danny there's no question is
that all of these vaccines all three of
them
block hospitalization and death 100 in
the clinical trials
while the number at 28 days showed that
you were 72
protected from virus from symptoms when
you go out a month or so those numbers
go up and it's a very long lasting
protection in fact
the johnson johnson vaccine has shown
the best protection against a south
african variant
so it's an excellent vaccine it's one
and done it is not getting a second
place vaccine
all three of them take whichever you can
get first a day earlier means a day
earlier you are protected
i got to tell you my heart sank hearing
dr fauci say by the end of the summer or
fall is when all americans who want a
vaccine should be able to get one
are we going to see a return to normalcy
in summer somewhat as we see more people
vaccinated at least
well no question about it is that there
will be enough vaccines the president
said last week
for all adults by may and so this summer
if you uh get a vaccine and you're with
other people who are vaccinated the
restraints or the the restrictions will
go down and down
so we're not going to have a normal
summer but we're going to be able to do
many of the things that we haven't been
able to do for the last year
the vaccine science is going to get us
out of this pandemic and allow us to
live a more normal life
it was a year ago you told us we had to
get ready for a new normal and
you were right you are right now dr
david agus thank you we appreciate it